une association pour se retrouver autour
de l'histoire des arts martiaux et
pratiquer vous l'avez compris avec ce
garçon ça s'appelle de taille et des
stocks aller sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment et taper de taille et des
stocks et derrière cette chose
bizarroïde et ce nom pour moi qui n'y
connaissait rien avant de vous
rencontrer et bien on découvre des
passionnés et vous vous avez tout à fait
votre place ici vous êtes vous aussi
formidable comme votre voisine
d'ailleurs hein votre voisine qui a
décidé de nous parler d'avenir on va pas
parler du vôtre le vôtre ça sera un peu
plus long on en parlera peut-être à la
fin de l'émission mais plutôt celui de
du rêve des êtres humains depuis
toujours celui d'être plus fort je pense
pas que votre voisin me démentissent
plus rapide et de ne pas vieillir
notamment grâce à la recherche
scientifique il faut m'expliquer là mais
oui parce qu'elle parce que vous le
savez alors on s'intéresse au passé moi
j'étais sur Cyrano de Bergerac là avec
mon voisin j'étais sur Arsène Lupin
voilà tous ces personnages qui étaient
équipés d'armes mais à l'heure actuelle
on rêve aussi du futur d'être un homme
augmenté et ça fait longtemps puisque
avant on parlait d'hommes bionique vous
savez on rêvait artificiel mais Steve
Austin
alors avec ce livre là de la tête aux
pieds de Florence Pinault qui est publié
aux éditions Nathan et bien on revient
sur ces inventions qui nous rendent plus
fort et ils partent vraiment dans le
temps puisque il nous parle par exemple
du bonnet en laine ou des échasses on a
tendance à oublier que c'est des
inventions finalement qui nous ont
protégé et il nous explique aussi et
bien ce qui nous fait grandir à l'heure
actuelle avec des innovations qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément qui nous
permettent et bien voilà de d'augmenter
de rendre plus fort nos cinq sens et nos
organes vitaux par exemple est-ce que
vous savez qu'on en est au basket
imprimé en 3D sur notre morphologie pour
pouvoir courir plus vite ou au short
aussi robotisés vous en avez pas parce
qu'elle vous non
on fabrique des pour le dos pour réduire
les douleurs chroniques et même des
rétines artificielles pour aider les
non-voyants avoir tout ça c'est dans ce
livre et je trouve ça vraiment super de
pouvoir expliquer ça aux enfants et de
regarder très très loin bon en ce moment
vous le savez de grands sujets de
préoccupation c'est l'intelligence
artificielle on en parle beaucoup là il
y avait une bague philo il y a peu de
temps il y a eu un philosophe contre
chaque GPT un peu de mal à le dire parce
que c'est une machine n'est-ce pas là il
y a un animateur québécois spécialiste
du sujet qui a décidé d'y consacrer tout
un album jeunesse c'est ça oui tout à
fait ça s'appelle IAS comment les
machines pourraient nous remplacer et
l'animateur est bien c'est Mathieu Dugal
il avait fait un documentaire une série
documentaire pour la télévision
québécoise et il s'est dit bah moi je
vais expliquer ça aux enfants c'est un
documentaire très intéressant et très un
livre documentaire ça s'appelle aussi
d'ailleurs très accessible puisqu'il est
illustré par des dessins très pop on
revient aussi dans le temps avec ce
livre et on parle justement de chat GPT
un qui peut écrire à la manière des
grands écrivains c'est très ludique je
le conseille à partir de 8 ans mais
jusqu'à
100 ans bon on peut pas attendre
s'entendre parce qu'il nous reste 2
minutes 15 d'émissions donc le temps de
vous remercier très officiellement de
toute l'équipe et de tous mes camarades
de France 3 Bourgogne Franche-Comté
d'avoir été avec nous pendant ces
quelques années vous allez voguer vers
d'autres horizons du côté de Royan pour
être un peu plus précis n'est ce pas
vous saluez vos enfants Eric et Suzanne
et on pourra faire des beaux châteaux de
sable ça va être sympa
j'espère bien